[Music]
so my passion for economics I it comes
from many sources I think the biggest
one is for the benefit of humanity or
mankind as we used to call it in
humanity and also not just humanity but
for the broader world around us I
thought when I first began working on
economics that it was that it was clear
that there were many economic problems
that were unsolved I think the ones I
were most interested in when I first
started with poverty and macroeconomics
are business cycles and I still were I
still am interested in those but I IV
rode off into other areas particularly
environmental economics and Resource
Economics later but I think the big
passion was I thought economics was a
tool that one could use like like a
carpenter used as a tool to build
something it was a intellectual tool
that could be used to improve people's
well-being
[Music]
my upbringing in in New Mexico I'd say
was it was very focused on the outdoors
my father was interested in the outdoors
he was interested in skiing and fishing
and building things interesting things
like tramways he was interested in
Indian law at that time and in the later
part of his life became one of the
nation's leading Indian lawyers so all
of this had to do with the outdoors and
so when I moved east to a more urban
environment I had that in my background
[Music]
the in my interest in climate change was
a natural outgrowth of interests that
evolved over time so when I first became
a serious became seriously interested in
economics in graduate school I was
primarily interested in economic growth
I think it's quite interesting that the
prize this year which is really about
economic growth was what was my interest
actually has been my interest all my
life in economics and I started working
on that and I started working on
technology and for four or five years I
worked on exactly the same area that
Paul Romer got his prize for but I gave
it up I it was too hard so it just was
too hard for me so I moved on and then I
started worrying about some but it was
the same issue that that the technology
Romer work deals with which is that
markets cannot solve certain problems
markets are very good at some things
they allocate bread they allocated
gasoline but they they don't allocate
technology efficiently and they don't
allocate energy and environmental issues
efficiently so I was always interested
in these byproducts of a climate of
economic I was always interested in the
byproducts of economic growth and so I
worked first on energy and then I worked
I worked on energy for well I've always
worked on energy I should say and then
gradually looked at some of the
byproducts of energy production and that
very quickly led to climate change I
think it was that the the place that
sort of crystallized that for me was in
1974 I went to the new Institute that
had been formed in Vienna called the
International Institute for applied
systems analysis or Yassa and at that
time and it's a it was you know just an
extraordinary crop of brilliant
brilliant people director howard raiffa
from Harvard my colleague telling
Koopmans Alan man from Stanford being
among them and there was a man named
Alan Murphy I shared brilliant
climatologist I shared an office with
and so we naturally got started and he
said well why don't you think about this
and so I started to thinking about
climate change
[Music]
I think the main message of the forum is
not just my work but the work of people
in the area of climate change economics
the integrated assessment modeling as
it's called a technical name is really
twofold one is it's to see the climate
climate change problem as a byproduct an
unintended byproduct of economic growth
and then the second thing is to
understand that what we need to do is we
need to correct that by fixing the price
of emissions
so now emissions are free in most places
not in Sweden but all everyplace else in
the world outside of Western Europe when
you emit a ton of carbon dioxide you
don't probably know you're doing it or
think of doing it probably and you drive
your car or you will have a product that
has combustion behind it that you're
putting in the atmosphere and you're
causing damage but you're not paying
anything for it so the inside of
economics is what you go through that
and you analyze it it to say we need to
put a price on these and that way you
know give people incentives to reduce
their use of carbon fuels and or the
products that use carbon fuels and
thereby reduce their emissions so it's
the key messages of economics is that
this is this is a flaw in the market and
it's correctable if governments take
steps to change the price from zero to a
high enough price that you can meet your
targets so that data that a semantics is
pretty easy to explain but then the next
step is what is that price and I think
the most interesting thing about all the
work I've ever done is that in building
models of this the price just comes out
of it it's just one of the byproducts of
of the it's called linear programming is
that
technical name for it but it has another
technical thing called a dual variable
which is this is the price that you
should set on carbon dioxide emissions
if you're going to meet your goal and
it's a yeah I think of it as kind of a
mathematical miracle in the sense that
you can do this and then out pops the
price that the government should set
well my message is you by yourself can
do nothing there are too many people
doing too much for too many generations
of people so even if I'm the most
ethical person or even if I'm not just
an ethical person that I'm going to
represent ten or a hundred other people
who are not so ethical or don't care
about it the the effect I alone and I
want to emphasize the word
alone will have is insignificant it's
like a billionth of a billionth or
trillionth of what is necessary so what
is necessary is that people act through
their governments and their government
to act together with other nations to to
take steps to solve this problem I don't
want to say there's a single step you
can take because there are multiple
things to do but I'd say the message is
you need to exercise your your duties
and responsibilities as citizens as
voters or places where they're not
voters is there no democracies as
protesters work through governments work
through nonprofit organizations a work
through schools to to persuade people
that we need to take steps to do this
there's nothing wrong with taking the
step by yourself to curb your own need
to curb your own emissions or to turn
the heat down or whatever there that's
fine but but that by itself is not
sufficient
well I've been working on this long
enough to see that things change and
change slowly I'd say over the period
since I've been working I started
working on this in the 1970s there's
been there's been a lot of progress in
the science the social sciences is what
the Natural Sciences I've seen
considerable change in viewpoint of
professionals of scientists interested
scientists of concerned citizens so I
think there's a now a great really great
realization of the problem the solutions
and so on so in that in that respect I
think it's been a good moment at the
same time the politics has moved
backwards in in the last say last couple
of years maybe more maybe maybe even a
little bit more with people particularly
the American president who makes
ludicrous statements about climate
change but I think it's spread it's a
little spread so there's a we have in
all of our big countries we have
problems of leaders who are really not
not thinking about global problems
they're not even thinking about problems
often in a sensible way so it's what I
like to say is two steps forward one
step backwards maybe it's a big step
backward now but I I'm hopeful that we
will get over that and move forward
again
[Music]
people often learn their social
political scientific views when they're
in school and they they get hardwired
into their brain and their emotions and
it's sometimes very difficult for people
to to change so often our leaders will
be taught things 20 30 40 50 years old
and so they're not really ready for the
challenges of today they're not ready
for the challenges of climate climate
change is one example
another one is cybersecurity I mean I
think the people have the people in
leadership in the world don't actually
know anything about about information
technology so how can they appreciate
the threats of it and I think that's now
changing a little bit but I think when
it first Cammi you say oh these people
know nothing about computers how can
they possibly understand the threats of
cybersecurity so it's a little the same
climate change they grew up they went to
college so I view the most important job
that I do is is teaching because you see
people and at college age I think of 18
to 22 they're the most amazing open and
plastic minds I'm just I'm just
absolutely astounded this student will
come in at the beginning but I just say
teach macroeconomics and Allu nothing no
nothing about international trade
nothing about how the exchange rates
work they will know nothing about how
the economy is affected and by the end
of the time they they basically they
basically know what a professional
economist knows and it's and it's just
so easy and then they'll and they'll you
know they'll forget half of it of course
but it's somewhere deep in their brain
they'll know it so when they run into it
five or ten or twenty or thirty years
later say oh yes I learned that at Yale
so it's it's this this is the generation
I love working with because there's a
there's a brilliance of mind but also
plasticity and an ability to absorb
new ideas and to challenge also to
challenge when I went poor ideas are put
to them so that's what teaching means to
me
[Music]
I had so many of them and I was I was
just blessed both at Yale as an
undergraduate at MIT as a graduate
student and then in a way is also in my
professional life as having so many
teachers that teachers and and often
later colleagues and co-authors well I
think the one that I particularly in
this particularly in this area in
climate change the one I particularly
point to would be telling Copeland's
challenge uplands was he was Dutch and
he he left he left Holland right before
World War two he was very much aware of
the lament of the Nazi menace in in
Western Europe I went to America he
again worked in America on mathematics
and invented his is a very important
that a linear program technique when he
was working on shipping convoys in World
War two went to Chicago that he came to
Yale and he was a colleague and
colleague at Yale and he influenced me
not just because he was interested in in
energy and climate change but because of
his enthusiastic and also his mentor
shivers I wasn't really mentor at that
stage was more his uh his enthusiasm for
the subject and his enthusiasm for my
work and the techniques he used were
ones that I they were different from
what everyone else is using and they've
said what I pointed out to earlier this
business about the shadow price the dual
variable that gives you the price of
carbon this came out of work he did and
if I hadn't used that technique I
wouldn't have found it
and actually I think he he he was the
first person I ever found mentioned
climate change even a Nobel lectures of
speeches and I did in the December of
1975 he actually mentioned it in his
toast at the banquet so he I just
mentioned him because he was a wonderful
colleague
a brilliant brilliant
Nobel prize-winning economist and just
very generous and a man as well but
there were many many others but under
since in this context I would
particularly associate with Charlie
Koopmans
[Music]
I think it's wonderful it's wonderful to
be to share this with Paul Romer for
lots of reasons
one is I have a great admiration for his
work what Paul Romer got the prize for
as he will explain is is opening up the
box of technological change in the
earlier work that had been done in
economic growth the work that I do learn
in graduate school technological change
was taken as a given it was just what's
what's known as exogenous that me
instead of falling from heaven and not
produced by humans it just it just comes
to you and everybody knew that's wrong
everybody knows if we produce great
technologies we you know we produce the
steam engine and the idea for the steam
engine and the steam engine the idea for
the transistor and the transistor and
modern electronics the idea for the
telephone and then the telephone and how
telecommunications everybody knows that
well it didn't just come floating down
from some intellectual heaven but it was
invented by people but it wasn't in our
models and so this was this was we knew
this and we'd actually tried to I
actually tried to work on that myself as
I said it was too hard so I gave it up
but that was the problem that Paul Romer
tackled and saying it solved and and
produced this really brilliant new way
of thinking about technologies so I
think it's it's really nice for me to
share it with Paul partly because that
was a problem I thought about and worked
on and and failed at when and when I was
a graduate student and then partly also
coming to today because it's clear that
the solutions to problems like climate
change involved exactly what he's
talking about
finding ways to induce new technologies
finding ways to get people to think
about them to develop invent them to
develop the products and processes to
make sure they're commercial to get them
out in the world so these are this is
the issue he thought and using his
insights in the climate change area
so marrying those two is I think a
critical critical need and then over the
next few years if we're to succeed one
of the things is to understand it's not
a linear process it's not you sit down
with the blank piece of paper I know you
know I know you nobody thinks this but
just to emphasize you sit down to the
backseat of paper you say climate change
and underline it and say number one
number two number three and say okay
there's the problem let's go solve it so
often things will occur while you're
outside walking around well you'll see
something when you'll talk to somebody
where you're maybe sometimes actually an
art exhibit will will stimulate some
thinking a problem obviously problems
and you see problems for example a woman
one an example of a problem was when in
2002 2003 when the US was about to go to
war in Iraq and then we were just
marching marching on his back World War
one and a few Europeans will know the
history of World War one they're
marching much sleep walking into history
so to speak and we were just marching
along it wasn't a hundred percent but
it's pretty clear and the question is
how costly is this gonna be and so I
started working on the cost of the Iraq
war did a pretty big study on that but
that's that was one where they you just
there's a problem is right in front of
you and you say well how much is this
gonna cost do we yeah we thought about
the costs of this talk to people well
yes it's not going to be very expensive
but of course instead of fifty billion
dollars it's like two three four
trillion dollars I'm just vastly vastly
under estimating but that's something
where it's a problem Orion other times
it's just curiosity just some the an
example of a curiosity was oh I was
thinking about light and whether we're
measuring
life correctly and so they that just
something I thought about it and then I
forgot about and then I thought about
another year later a fella
and then something would happen I'd see
something is they're all that's how to
do that and and then I got interested in
and worked intensive Lee on it so and
it's at you usually this sometimes the
problems have done just pure curiosity
about something when you want to was it
measured correctly for exactly in the
lighting is a good example with lighting
there was a big it was there's the
background of lighting was it was a big
controversy about whether price indexes
were being measured correctly this was
particularly in the United States and
there was a big report by a Stanford
colleague named Mike Bosca and the
Boston report and he are you that the
Consumer Price Index the United States
was seriously miss measured and that
looked right and part of the problem was
we weren't measuring quality change
correctly so that looks right and and I
looked at some other price indexes like
European price indexes are even worse
than the u.s. price indexes so then at
that point I said well what about light
I'll be measuring the price of light
correctly so at that point then I would
say well how are we gonna measure we've
got a you know we can look at different
sources of oil electricity compact
fluorescent that was before the LED bulb
and then you say well we're measuring
incorrectly because we're measuring them
by the price of the light bulb rather
than how much it costs to produce a
certain number of lumen hours so that
was just I'd say that was just pure
curiosity that drove then
I've received obviously as many nobilis
laureates do a lot of emails in these
days emails few phone calls a few
letters and then personal
congratulations from colleagues that I
knew and knew no hey no in New Haven and
friends and I think the most interesting
thing that about it is that yeah this
particular award that for climate change
I'm a nerd
yes it's economics but people think this
is an award for somebody who's working
on climate change and people think this
is this is like a light you know in a
dark time and they see this as as as a
very important institution they're
really the premier scientific award
institution of the world saying to the
world and and particularly America I
mean this is they're Americans I think
particularly useful to Americans to take
heart even if I don't think the Nova I
don't say you're saying this is what
they think you're saying the people and
why they're so happy about it is because
they think they're saying you're saying
take heart there's good work out there
there are people who care about you in
the United States and the rest of the
world and just stay with it keep art and
and we have people are working working
for good so I think it was very
interesting and I think I'm very
grateful for that particularly the that
it gives kind of courage and heart to
the people who were who were on the
right side of history
you
[Music]